it falls to sergeant Tracy Skinner to
locate the gangbangers and keep them
under control it made some gangs use
hand signs like these to show their
allegiance but that doesn't make
groaning up active gang members and
easier it's sergeant Skinner's job to
pull out these gangsters from general
population and put them in a special
housing unit this is what Skinner calls
phishing by taking all the sharks out of
the fish tank and put all the Sharks
over here I looked at the Guppies can
swim safely we're gonna come and see if
we find you know and gang activity
gather any intelligence we can gather
first Skinner must find out who's a
gangster to carry out orders gang
members must stay off prison staffs
radar denial is key you sure you have
the jump
think I'm
looks like a crip to me I don't gangbang
skinners primary technique casual
conversation don't play his card the
goal revealed gang connections you know
we we try to talk to them like they talk
to each other you know because they'll
they associate with it better he hopes
to get inmates to open up about what
happened over new ones know what
happened Oh Serena and Tracy got on got
it on over there too it is a game you
know it's it's cops and robber game you
know they're playing it with us we're
playing with them it's a big game
Skinner's next step sifter three inmates
pictures drawings and letters gangs
communicate in their own way what do you
got oh this one uses a written code to
keep their message under wraps see I'm
talking about where's our Swasey oh yeah
this right here is your Bruns who is it
so we got us one we get the jackpot
today what we'll do is well actually
well can you continue going through
stuff get everything that we found he's
telling him you know why you'd roll up
stuff you're coming with us right now oh
he's going it's already done deal
this gangbanger is part of an Aryan
ruler one of many nationwide prison
gangs here the gangs in Utah you know
they're very serious because what
they're doing is they're they're
watching what's going on in California
and they want to one-up California